no matter what fps you play there are
good guns
and there are bad guns whether it's
twitch's f2 in rainbow six or the ever
goated ak in cs go there are weapons
that we make sacrifices to get in our
hands versus protecting us holding the
angle very smartly indeed continuation
spray that is one of the most absurd
things i have seen and yet in the still
nascent history of valorant one question
has plagued every player that's ever
queued into a server
phantom
or vandal you see there are certain
close to medium range spray downs that
can only be committed with a phantom
corner you can play in and he plays it
perfectly the spam comes up and it's a
great transfer on to three looking for a
four just as there are truly tantalizing
tap fests that can only come courtesy of
the vandal now the duelists are starting
to come through
virtually every competitor swears by
either one or the other
but
why well what we're here to figure out
is whether one of them is actually
better than the other whether it's all a
question of personal preference or
whether using one of them in all or
certain situations
can actually offer you a competitive
advantage
oh my god you can't do that without the
vandal you can do that with a vendor
okay so before we start tapping and
spraying please be sure to like the
video subscribe to the channel and turn
on notifications i'll be honest i didn't
write like a cheeky thing for this one
just
do those things alright so whenever you
hop into a valorant server and you
stumble your way into the first by round
there is a very important question that
you must ask yourself
which rifle do you buy the phantom
or the vandal the vandal and the phantom
are the most important and most used
weapons in the entire game of valorant
and despite having the exact same cost
they're actually quite different sure at
their most basic core they're modeled
after the ak and the m4a4 slash a1s from
cs go respectively but it's not that
simple the phantom has 30 round mags
with a higher rate of fire while the
vandal has 25 round mags and a slower
rate of fire but what really sets these
weapons apart is their damage at
distance the vandal is able to one tap
heads and four tap torsos from any range
since there's no damage drop off the
phantom on the other hand does have a
drop off at 15 to 30 meters it only does
140 damage to the head and from 30 to 50
meters it only headshots for 124 and if
you've ever played valorent you know
that
hitting someone on the head for 140 is
just about the most infuriating [ __ ]
ever almost as annoying as the deagle
not one shot headshotting from long
range doing 140 to someone and not dying
it's just it's just sad like you don't
even know i don't even know what to say
nice okay so let's get into the
nitty-gritty of it because there are two
features that the vandal has that are
very important and will probably help
you make your decision as i'm sure you
can tell the phantom is silenced meaning
that bullet tracers are not visible to
enemies which means you can spray
through smokes and walls all you want
without getting punished for it since
enemies won't know where exactly the
shots are coming from try doing that
with the vandal
gonna have a bad time
what the [ __ ] am i doing but where the
phantom really takes the cake is with
respect to first shot accuracy its 0.2
first shot spread makes it the second
most accurate gun in the entire game
what is the most accurate you ask
well it is none other than hiko's
boomer friendly head bopper the guardian
now with the phantom your first bullet
should go exactly where you're aiming
almost every time assuming you aren't
moving but the vandal's .25 first shot
spread makes it more akin to the ak and
cs where every once in a while you might
actually be aiming at someone's head but
the shot just mysteriously misses now
this might not seem like a significant
difference but when you're taking you
know on average
10 to 20 gun fights per match
you're likely to experience it and
if you do
it might just cost you a kill
that's
needless to say the vandal does face
some minor inaccuracy issues and aside
from its damage fall off the phantom
beats it in pretty much every category
but with this being perhaps the most
pressing question in the entirety of
valorance meta we took it upon ourselves
to ask the pros
what are they because not all of them
use the phantom every time in fact for
some of them it's actually quite
situational i use both and i buy it
based off the position i'm in on the map
so if i'm like on attack bind and i'm
going long b i buy the vandal cause you
can't one top people at that range at
the phantom but if i'm playing a b on
breeze or i just sit like backside like
close to the entrance where like
everyone's like really close like
running in i use the phantom so it's
just like wherever it makes sense to use
it i have phantom i i think it more
often than not it bails me out than the
vandal does
uh it also gets me multi-frags a lot
more than the vandal does
spray transferring to different targets
is also much easier with the phantom
which isn't saying a lot for a game that
lacks set spray patterns but the
difference is noticeable now to some
pros the vandal is just more fun to use
on certain maps especially when they're
just trying to have fun in matchmaking i
switched between both but like i started
doing like
vandal on two maps so breeze and icebox
because they're very long distance
fights
some people say like shaz even says that
he's like if you're using the vandal for
those specific reasons like long
distance fights then
you're using it wrong like you're taking
the wrong fights but personally like in
ranked like i'm just taking fights you
know it doesn't matter so i'm just like
if it's a long distance fight like a
breeze that's a pretty big map like i
want to use a vandal i want to hit
someone for 140. the phantom is better
in every other
every other way like on buy and have in
all those maps i use a phantom because
you have more bullets you spray through
walls better recoil stuff like that the
bottom line is that broadly speaking the
phantom is just better full stop
in fact there's actually a sense in
which the weapon might be a little bit
too strong that said when it comes to
some pros you know the real gods
the choice really doesn't matter if
you're someone who has just insanely
nutty aim and a high headshot percentage
then using the vandal is absolutely
viable tapping or bursting can offer
some very solid results if your name
happens to be scream because god knows
there is nothing more satisfying than
hitting some insanely clean one taps but
generally speaking it's a gun for freaks
not for you to try to flex with in gold
the mantle's definitely better to watch
don't go wrong there are some players
that make the vandal look
at screen i prefer seeing screen with a
vandal um but then you look at players
like six zombs you know
shazam even to an extent with a
phantom's pretty disgusting when he's on
the jet still um
it's it's night and day to me the
counter rather of popping down the old
pushing mid to catch them away and
scream oh my god man head shot after
head shot that screen comes through to
ruin their day toronto's even native and
shut off the screen aces
now if you're one of those cs go scrubs
like myself who is kind of guilty of
spraying and praying with the phantom
whenever they play valor and learning to
you know tap and burst with the vandal
essentially
reverting back to my 1.6 self will take
some time it might take a while to break
the habit but i promise you that it's
worth it in the end because spraying
with the vandal just doesn't work as
well as it does with the phantom unless
of course you're chronicle
that dude's just cracked you gotta make
this happen crinkle he walks through and
destroys envy three
back-to-back frags and it might be four
in a second he's on the chopping block
gambit have made it to 12. now we've
heard what the pros have to say but what
about your everyday silver scrub like
like colton you think i'd be in silver
i mean considering i haven't even
installed the game i'll take that as a
compliment now one thing i did want to
touch on though is the assumption that
the vandal is stronger at long range due
to not having any damage drop off
because
there's more at play here than just
damage when i saw the 0.2 and 0.25
degree first bullet spread numbers it
got my math brain thinking since we know
those angles we can calculate what the
maximum spread on your first bullet will
be over different distances for each gun
and while the difference is relatively
small initially the further away your
target is the more pronounced the
difference in your first shot accuracy
which will ultimately lead to a larger
variance in the amount of shots you're
hitting regardless of how good your aim
is now i may not be your go-to source
for valor and gameplay tips mostly
because i don't play the game but one
thing i can give you some insight into
is what happens on the tech side during
your gun fight which may actually have a
bigger impact on your rifle choice than
you think and we're going to start with
hitscan hitscan is the method for
calculating bullet trajectories and hits
used for every gun and valerie the
bullets don't travel as physical objects
in the game engine rather the server
just calculates a line at the moment you
fire and checks to see if you hit
anything the other part of this equation
is that valorent is server authoritative
anything happening in your valorem game
is being simulated twice once on the
server and concurrently on your own
machine
so that it can smoothly predict movement
with a relatively rare update from the
server if anything begins to shift out
of place
this is true for movement as well as
combat because of this there is
ultimately going to be some travel time
between you pressing your left mouse
button the server getting that
information the server going back to the
frame of the simulation where that
button was pressed running the hitscan
calculation to see if slash what you hit
then sending that information back to
the player's pcs but the devs over at
riot have implemented some pretty
interesting solutions to keep your
gameplay and more specifically your
combat smooth and consistent like a
variable buffer size for updates from
players pcs reaching the server as well
as every valorent client updating its
movement physics and other related
systems at the same rate as the server
128 times every second regardless of
your game's frame rate now i know that
was a lot of pretty technical
information ultimately your hardware and
your ping to the valorant servers will
affect your experience with both the
phantom and the vandal
does the vandal hit considerably harder
past 30 meters yes does that necessarily
translate into more dps
statistically probably not whatever rank
you're at if you want to take valorent
seriously having a general understanding
of how things like hit registration and
netcode work is gonna help you when it
comes down to which rifle to buy and now
back to you dimitri so you can keep
telling the audience what the pros told
nile
the guy who actually wrote the script
anyway what i'm really getting at is
which one of these rifles
is more
noob friendly yep you probably guessed
it the phantom is by far the more
forgiving weapon to use the larger
magazine size and the higher rate of
fire just makes spraying the damn thing
a better option for beginners in fact if
you find yourself in a duel against a
fellow silver scrub and the two of you
are just going at it hitting a bunch of
shots at each other's toes because your
crosshair placement is so damn bad then
the phantom will just win out because
higher rate of fire means
more dps
now although the phantom is the more
accessible rifle i still recommend
swapping to the vandal in certain
situations like on icebox or breeze
where you know that you might be taking
longer range fights you have five extra
bullets with the phantom and it's easier
to spray like there's literally no
reason to use a vandal there like if you
pick a vandal over a fan on there like
it just makes no logical sense it's just
troll but if you if you're like using
the vandal on a if you're like defending
a we're like they're running out that
long like main hall and you're playing
far back like the vandals obviously
better like so they have it has their
situations there's not like ones better
than the others i think it's just
situational now like zom says you can
probably argue that on each map there
are certain areas where the vandal just
reigns supreme but for the most part
you're still better off sacrificing the
guaranteed one-shot headshot
for the phantom it doesn't help that
since valoren's release the game has
been plagued by run and gun issues the
penalty for shooting while running or
walking is so negligible and valorent
that you can often be rewarded for just
sprinting around corners and pre-firing
dudes with a phantom and sure you can
argue that it's possible to do this with
any weapon but with the phantom and the
spectre
it's busted riot even tried nerfing it
way back in june but it honestly wasn't
enough hell i still get killed by spray
bullets from some phoenix ferrari
peeking me out of garage
and that [ __ ] sucks
but at least we know that riot is
somewhat listening to the community's
concerns running and gunning might still
be a problem but riot have decided to
tackle it little by little for a reason
they can't just completely rework the
game's gun mechanics all at once
otherwise they risk breaking valorant
altogether and until it gets another
round of nerfs then nearly every top
competitor or at least those who want to
be as competitive as possible
are just gonna keep rocking the phantom
it's just the best rifle in the game and
there's really no arguing against that
even though sometimes when you're
feeling it the vandal can look sick i
think consistency wise phantom is just
the better gun sure using the vandal
pretending your scream and taking duels
can be fun in matchmaking but
if you want to take the game seriously
then there's pretty much no doubt that
as of right now
the phantom is the way to go this has to
be at this where they're gonna be up
still i'm gonna try and get that one
[Music]
you can see they're pretty happy about
that one
oh my dryer
this episode's sponsored by maytag
sponsored by maytag hey man maytag wants
to send me a new f-wording
dryer i'm absolutely game dude please be
my guest we can do a crack on washer
dryers right
100 easy
they've got to be able to run right now
yeah i'll i'll interview get right like
it'll be fine i'll just we'll get bolo
like talking about washer dryers
easy
but what about the silver scrubs like my
boy colton
[Music]